let's get into what's happening on our
reddit discussion forum david pakman.com
slash reddit we've got at this point
what is it close to 3,500 of our viewers
or listeners I think that are subscribed
their discussions about all sorts of
political issues going on david
pakman.com slash read it
let's take a look at a couple
interesting posts on our reddit that i
found this morning number one an
interesting post about Glenn Greenwald
supporting a relationship between Russia
and Donald Trump related to an interview
he did on Democracy Now very interesting
discussion I encourage you to check it
out also on our reddit discussion forum
an article about long dormant bacteria
bacteria and viruses trapped in ice and
permafrost for centuries that are
reviving as we have the climate of Earth
warming also on our reddit discussion
forum is everyone a Marxist and not
willing to admit it interesting little
hypothesis put together by one of our
audience members and a nice little
discussion happening about that also on
our reddit discussion forum Steve Eggman
made my day this is a viewer who was not
having a great day and really liked the
voicemail from the Eggman or as he's now
known Steve Eggman
Eggman if you are out there I have to
say thank you man I was just about on
the edge of a mental breakdown today and
hearing that voicemail saved my life he
does have a way of inspiring confidence
doesn't it yes he does yes he does and
lastly from our reddit discussion forum
an interesting post called perceptive
producer Pat pounces praising Pat
praising perceptive producer Pat who
pounced a lot of alliteration there for
pointing out that the racist lady from
Trader Joe's had a cart with only
avocados in it with only avocados in it
something Pat found odd and people in
the audience reacting really strongly to
that Pat they liked it well I just think
the fact that she had a cart full of
just a few avocados really encapsulates
her personality type as someone who's a
bit deranged and inconsiderate of
everyone else yeah I think that's clear
because why else would you take up the
entire checkout lane with a cart if all
you've got is four avocados and I think
the line of the segment was what what's
she in a hurry to do make guacamole and
and people really like that so anyway a
david pakman.com
read it check it out a lot of great
discussions going on there